how confident are you that restaurant
ears will be able to open their doors in
July we're all gonna make inhuman
attempts to to do that it's not going to
be easy because and the main reason for
that well there's a bunch of reasons but
the work is making it especially
difficult at the moment is that we
haven't received very clear guidelines
for government what that real opening is
going to look like there has been some
leaked documents talking about the
certain degrees of separations meant
menus that would have to be disposable
all that all those kind of ideas but but
we haven't had a very clear idea we've
had this fourth of July and date in the
diary quite a while without having any
kind of clarity about what would it mean
for us and we're in it we're an industry
that employs a lots and lots of people
and we need time to prepare
we don't just open a restaurant tomorrow
if there's going to be separation a
clear separation policy about perspex
dividers or glass dividers it's going to
be one meter or two meters we need to
know all that and we cannot put there
without that level of knowledge which is
really missing at the mall and actually
say a fourth enjoy a date not very long
away now in order to get ready to open
the doors at that point and there's a
review at the minute as you know of
course intercutting
that two meter social distancing rule to
one meter how important is that for
restaurant owners it's really vital
it makes the whole operation buyable to
a degree I don't think anyone is going
to be making money with the 1 meter rule
but at least we're going to survive and
I think survival is what we really need
to talk about because and people do not
understand that restaurants which are
jolly happy paying places where people
are having a good time and eating good
food and getting great service do rely
on a certain number of people coming in
through the door
there's not much cash in this industry
and we've been closed as you said from
longer than three months now and when we
reopen we're looking at capacity working
at a very low capacity 50 40 to 60
percent we really don't know so so that
lack of clarity makes things even worse
because at least we know we're preparing
for but we don't know what we're for so
I'm extremely worried because it's not
gonna be easy not at all
talking about survival there the UK
hospitality I bought either industry
represented body says that 2 metres 1/3
of hospitality businesses won't be able
to reopen in a million jobs would be
lost how many
I mean how worried are you about the
impact this could be on restaurants that
just may not be able to open oft it
again you know when people look at
restaurants a busy place you know with
things go they don't understand that
there's a whole little micro community
that add that these restaurants attract
obviously there's the local and
neighbourhood or offices around it but
there's all there's the staff you know
in front of house and back of house that
love what they're doing and create
things with great passion and you know
every day because they're not in it for
the money
and then there's the whole businesses
surrounding the restaurants there's the
farmers there's this of wine merchants
there's different suppliers there's
there's laundry services IT it's massive
industry that it gives employment to
millions and millions and if we don't
get the kind of support that we need
with the guidelines that I've mentioned
but also with financial because the
government has been very generous in
offering the furlough scheme that is it
has kept us propped up for a while and
all manner of loans but the biggest
problem that I've been banging on about
for a very long time are the rents we
most of us have not been paying paid
have not been paying rent since March
and are not expected to be paid paying
rent in June many many of us and this is
and then has not been sorted legally
this is not half the legal grounding
footing that we need in order to move
forward and
all restaurants I think 90% of the
restaurants will all go bust if the the
question of the rent rent is not going
to be sorted by government now recently
the government is proud to publish the
code of practice for commercial property
relationships between landlords and
tenants in which they urge us to come
together and find solutions to these
problems but I think something much
stronger is needed we were talking about
timeout and nine and nine months almost
a year and rent free but then it doesn't
address any of the landlord problems
with their debts but we really really
need government intervention to help us
save restaurants that would just not be
able to survive on their own
these RV landlords are the kind of
communication that they can afford to
have at this point in time just to
clarify what you were saying there about
the amount of restaurants that may go
under if the rent if they all have to
pay these kind of rate of payments how
many how many were you saying I don't
have a number I really don't know what
the statistic is but if you think of all
the rent that's been accumulating over
the last three months of closure plus
the extra debts that are going to
accumulate by having either not
operating or operating a very low
capacity into the future we just cannot
carry on paying the rent that we did now
for the rest to go down obviously you
could have a civilized conversations
between its compensation between
landlord and tenant but this hardly ever
happens that's just not our reality if
you're a big business with many many
many branches you know one of the big
chains then you've got the muscle and
the power and the money to negotiate and
play hard with your adults but if you're
a single operation or just a month
multiple and a small multiple operation
you just don't have the capacity to have
these hard conversations and if the
government doesn't come in with
legislation or any kind of guidance of
how to do it
these conversations might break down and
the businesses will suffer and I'm not
only talking about the restaurants as I
said there is a whole chain of suppliers
and other restaurants involved and I'm
also thinking of the landlords because
if they're going to lose a tenant
nobody else will come to fill in the
space this point in time because nobody
will open a restaurant at the moment
under current climate so we're in a very
very very tricky situation and we really
need some kind of guidance or government
intervention to solve this problem when
do you need the government guidance by
if restaurants are to open on the 4th of
July what was the latest time so we need
it now we really really need it now we
need to know how many people are we
allowed in what kind of distance we need
help you know how people are going to
queue if they're gonna leave us to our
own devices they might as well just say
it now and say ok guys you have to
really behave responsibly in order to
keep people safe and a certain degree of
businesses and go ahead and we're
opening on the 4th of July we can deal
with that
but the trouble is is that often we get
that we get the the the guidance very
very late in the day so after all these
months of lost business we're gonna have
a few more days of week of wealth of
lost business just getting into grips
with new guidelines that we've just
heard about at the very last minute
which is very very damaging for our
industry and just finally I cannot have
you on the program without asking the
last question that I've got we're all
doing lots more lockdown cooking lots of
cooking at home at the minute often with
kind of stall covered ingredients
because we can't get our hands on the
usual stuff they use you've got any tips
for cooking in lockdown my tip is
fritters so if you take if you have a
bit of flour and we have tins of
chickpeas or yes some cooked up
vegetables from the previous day you mix
it all together with eggs with some
jumped-up certain spices but everything
you have and you shallow fry it and
serve it with a bit of cream or yogurt
or the squeeze of lemon you're okay
grown-up children everybody's happy